most triumphant we're finally getting a
three quell in the saga bill s
preston esquire and ted theodore logan
while we can't travel into the future to
watch bill and ted face the music right
now we've rounded up everything we know
about their next and assuredly most
excellent adventure
before he was johnny utah johnny
mnemonic or john wick keanu reeves
endeared himself to audiences as the
lovable dim-witted ted theodore logan
who wanted nothing more than to make a
triumphant music video and become a
famous rock star
opposing ted was his rigid father whose
threats of sending his son away to
military school
motivated ted to do whatever it took to
pass his history class and stay at san
dimas high school
reeves has been talking about a bill and
ted sequel for years although a decade
ago it barely resembled the movie in its
current form
back in 2008 when reeves talked to mtv
about a third bill in ted he said it
would be a remake that wouldn't
necessarily involve him
although he still spoke affectionately
about the possibility even back then
though the seed for face the music
seemed to have been germinating in
reeves imagination
with him saying i had once mentioned
about doing it when we were 40. now
maybe the only shot we have is to do it
when we're 50.
turns out he was close reeves will be
turning 56 just one day after face the
music arrives
but now yeah i'm thinking i'm back
as much as we all love keanu reeves bill
and ted doesn't work without a bill
fortunately alex winter is just as
stoked as reeves to be returning to the
role that made him famous
as long as it's done right speaking to
indy wire in 2018 about a possible third
film winter said we've been pretty
philosophical about it like if we could
get it made great but if it's not going
to get made to our creative
specifications we're all perfectly happy
not doing it
fortunately winter seems to agree with
the consensus that face the music is
indeed the film the original creative
team
wanted to make it will be winter's first
major starring role in more than 25
years
after he walked away from acting to
pursue his passion for documentary
filmmaking and to give himself space to
heal from the trauma of his childhood
in recent years winter has made several
documentary films focusing on technology
including downloaded and deep web and
says that making documentaries is quote
the most creatively gratified i've ever
been
still winter was excited to take a short
hiatus from documentaries to step back
into bill's high-top sneakers and
inexplicable crop top
winter added that i really just need to
turn that entire side of my brain off
and be the dumbass that bill is for
three months
although we're pretty sure that bill and
ted face the music wouldn't dare kill
bill and ted again there's still going
to be some role for death to play in
their midlife crisis
william sadler is reprising his role as
the grim reaper who failed to
permanently collect the souls of the
wild stallions in bill and ted's bogus
journey and subsequently became their
servant
you have sank my battleship
excellent yeah
no further details have been revealed
about how death will figure into bill
and ted face the music or whether he'll
be functioning as an ally or an
antagonist to the two adorably
bone-headed heroes
who knows maybe he's still a member of
wild stallions on the upright base
or has become a superstar in his own
right following a resurgence of the
popularity of his reaper rap
just when you thought that bill and ted
based the music's road to release
couldn't get any more heartwarming the
production had to go and announce the
names of bill and ted's daughters
ready or not actress samara weaving will
be playing thea preston while bridget
lundy payne will be portraying billy
logan
yes bill and ted named their daughters
after each other this was technically
revealed at the end of bogus journey
though many fans simply assumed that
little bill and little ted were boys
as writer ed solomon pointed out on
twitter though the kids were played by
girls to begin with
producer scott crump described weaving
and lundy payne as quote funny and
unique to entertainment weekly and said
that seeing them together was like the
first time they ever saw winter and
reeves as bill and ted
according to the film's official
synopsis billy and thea will be
instrumental in helping their dads write
the song that will save the universe
one of the most excellent parts of bill
and ted's first time hopping adventure
was their stop in medieval england where
they rescued princesses joanna and
elizabeth bill and ted went on to marry
the two princesses off screen at the end
of bogus journey during their 16 months
of intensive guitar training and arrived
back at battle of the bands carrying
their infant children on their backs
now the princesses are back although
they've been recast for face the music
jaime mays of glee fame will play bill's
wife joanna aaron hayes will play
elizabeth logan
where not for ted's strict father bill
and ted may never have felt the need to
work so hard to pass history and embark
on their first voyage through time
so it's only fitting that the logan
family will be back for face the music
led by hal landon jr who will be
reprising his role as ted's father
meanwhile beck bennett will be taking
over the role of ted's brother deacon
replacing frasier bane whose career has
shifted from acting to producing
hopefully after 30 years captain logan
will have mellowed out a bit when it
comes to his desire to control his son
but we wouldn't be surprised if the
captain still somehow manages to work
the phrase military school into
conversation
meanwhile amy stoach is also returning
as bill's disturbingly youthful
ex-stepmom missy who married his dad
before the start of bill and ted's
excellent adventure
only to divorce him and marry ted's dad
before bogus journey at the end of that
film it's implied that missy divorces
captain logan too
then gets engaged to the villainous
denomilos although it's never confirmed
as she goes through with the wedding
it's unclear what role she'll play in
the adult bill and ted's lives and face
the music but we're sure that however
missy factors in it's sure to make bill
uncomfortable
step bombs q shut up ted you know when
she was a senior we were friends shut up
ted
although bill and ted fans have long
been champion at the bit to see our
favorite time traveling bozos back in
action we had a long wait to see any
actual footage from face the music to
tie this over while we waited for an
official trailer keanu reeves and alex
winter
introducing themselves in character as
wild stallions filmed a short video at
the hollywood bowl
in the video the pair first announced
the threequel in its title
thanked fans for sticking with them and
ended by reminding all of us to be
excellent
finally in june 2020 orion pitchers
delivered the full trailer for bill and
ted based the music
and it quickly became clear that the
ride would be worth the wait the sneak
peek offered our first look at our
middle-aged heroes their kids and their
old friend death
a second trailer followed promising a
return trip to hell and setting up the
most dire stakes of the mission
it's clear from what we've seen so far
that the classic wild stallion style of
fun is alive and well and we can't wait
to see more in september
the only major bill and ted character
not returning to face the music is the
duo's time-traveling mentor rufus played
by legendary comedian george carlin who
passed away in 2008
rather than recast rufus or attempt to
sweep his absence under the rug
ed solomon says that the third bill and
ted film will serve as a tribute to both
the character and the actor who
portrayed him
solomon said in an interview with
digital spy in 2018
george carlin is so deeply missed by all
of us there is a not just a homage to
him it's more than that his absence is
part of the whole movie
solomon went on to reveal that bass and
music will see bill and ted interact
with their younger selves and rufus by
incorporating footage of carlin
along with the younger reeves in winter
from bill and ted's excellent adventure
while rufus may be gone in the upcoming
sequel he definitely won't be forgotten
be excellent to each other
[Music]
although bill and ted actually learned
how to play their instruments and
seemingly became famous at the end of
bogus journey the trailers for face the
music tell us that they never did
compose the greatest song ever written
middle age will find them feeling the
pressure of a destiny unfulfilled
according to writers chris matheson and
ed solomon the script tackles the
pressure of being told they're going to
save the world
and not having done it yet and of being
50 and wondering if you should give up
on the dreams you still haven't achieved
you totally blew it dude the
screenwriters went on to explain that
the idea felt much more interesting than
telling a bill and ted's story in which
they'd already become famous save the
world and had some kind of falling out
solomon told ew
i think it's kind of like a christmas
carol with bill and ted looking at their
lives and really kind of rediscovering
what they're about
the script for bill and ted pays the
music has gone through a lot of changes
since solomon and matheson first pitched
the idea to reeves
in winter in 2007. however one thing
that's always remained constant is
everyone's desire to make a film that
feels like it belongs alongside
excellent adventure and bogus journey
no one involved wanted to lose the
elements that made bill and ted special
and it sounds as though they've
succeeded reeves told ew
i love the characters so much who they
are the spirit of their voice at chris
and eddie given them
winter added the whole trajectory of
getting the next one off the ground has
been pretty much
exactly like the experience of getting
the original going to every studio and
they're like what the f
is this it's kind of independent spirit
and the films have an anachronistic
quality to them that's a big part of
what they are fundamentally
i'm really happy that this one is the
same ever since the official synopsis
for bill and ted based in music was
revealed we've known that the plot would
revolve around the two main characters
facing the pressure of not having yet
written their world-saving song as they
stare down the barrel of retirement age
however it now sounds as though the
window in which the duo must deliver
their song is much narrower than we
previously thought
speaking to ew about bill and ted's
predicament in the prequel
writer chris matheson revealed they've
got literally 80 minutes or all of
reality will come to an end
with less time to save the world than it
would take to watch either of their
previous two movies bill and ted will
have to make every second count if
they're going to have a chance of
succeeding
fortunately it sounds like they'll have
help from a variety of sources including
their daughters and kid cudi's character
who is apparently
kid cudi director dean parasot told ew
he plays kid cudi he gets mysteriously
thrown through various times
because all time and space is coming
unglued whether perishop meant that
cuddy will play a fictional character
similar to his real-life persona or an
alternate reality version of himself
we'll have to wait until the movie
arrives on september 1st to find out
all we can do is hope that it's
excellent
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one